big numbers in small spaces simulating
atoms molecules at Brownian motion how
many molecules are in a single drop of
water or a single cell let's fly in and
find out
this may look realistic but it isn't
you're only seeing about one out of
every thousand water molecules here's
how they look at full density this cube
is only three nanometers or three
billions of a meter on each side its
volume was only 27 billions of a
billionth of a billionth of a cubic
meter but the water molecules are so
small and packed together so tightly
that there are about 900 in this tiny
space to put this into perspective think
of a red blood cell which is about seven
microns or seven millionths of a meter
in diameter
more than 140 red blood cells laid side
by side could fit into a single
millimeter and yet the volume of each
cell could hold about three trillion
water molecules
in each water molecule two hydrogen
atoms are bonded to a single oxygen atom
each atom is shown as a sphere even
though it actually consists of protons
and neutrons in the nucleus and
electrons that travel around the nucleus
at speeds that may approach the speed of
light the size of each sphere is
determined by the atoms Vander Waals
radius named after Johannes diderik van
der waals winner of the 1910 Nobel Prize
in Physics two atoms joined by a
covalent bond share electrons and have
overlapping van der Waals radii the
bonds themselves are not rigid
instead you can think of them as Springs
that stretch and flex at very high speed
to simulate their motions we have to
take tiny steps through time using
Newton's equations of motion a method
called molecular dynamics because of the
tiny time step molecular dynamics
simulations are very time-consuming even
on supercomputers as shown here the time
step is usually about one femtosecond or
one millionth of one billionth of a
second the bonds between the atoms are
only about one angstrom long or one
tenth of a billionth of a meter and with
very short time steps you can see the
atoms moving as if in slow motion on the
other hand the entire water molecule
seems to be hanging in space since its
overall motion is much slower than the
motions of the individual atoms when we
show the surrounding water molecules
again you can see that the atoms of
different molecules overlap very little
because they are not covalently bonded
to each other you can also see molecules
disappearing and reappearing at the
edges of the box this is a technique
called periodic boundary conditions
where molecules can jump to opposing
sides by wrapping interactions around
the box the simulation mimics an
infinite volume without adding more
water molecules
it also means nothing is needed to hold
the water like the glass walls of a
beaker this simplifies the calculations
and reduces the computation time
as you watch the molecules move you can
see another kind of force at work
between neighbors although it is much
weaker than a covalent bond notice how
it keeps adjacent hydrogen and oxygen
atoms facing each other while they
vibrate this helps the molecules pack
together tightly and restrains their
motion for short periods of time these
special interactions occur with hydrogen
atoms and are called hydrogen bonds when
other molecules are dissolved they also
interact with the surrounding water here
you can see a single molecule of
dissolved glucose a simple sugar
composed of carbon hydrogen and oxygen
atoms at very short times you can see
the vibrations of the atoms as they
interact with the invisible layer of
surrounding water over longer times the
surrounding layer changes as hydrogen
bonds are broken and reformed between
different atoms as this occurs the
glucose molecule will change position
and will appear to make stepwise
movements of different lengths in random
directions you can see this effect as
the movie speeds up in a simulation
appears to be taking longer time steps
from these periodic snapshots you can
see the net displacement of the glucose
molecule as well as faster atomic
vibrations over longer times in several
hundred femtoseconds the range of steps
can be calculated without all the
underlying atomic interactions this is
done using a diffusion coefficient
originally defined by Albert Einstein
and other scientists it depends on
Boltzmann's constant temperature the
viscosity of the solution and the size
of the molecule with a diffusion
coefficient we can simulate diffusion or
Brownian motion just by moving the
molecule in a random direction to a net
distance chosen from a range of values
pre computed for the chosen time step
this approach is called browny and
dynamics and requires far fewer
calculations than molecular dynamics
to illustrate in the movie we now
replace the molecular dynamic snapshots
with a Brownian dynamic simulation as
shown by the growing path we calculate
only a new position for the entire
molecule after each time step of 300
Center seconds in other words we no
longer have to calculate atomic
interactions with the surrounding water
in steps of the single femtosecond the
end result is stepwise movements that
match snapshots from molecular dynamics
with Brownian dynamics the time step can
be increased and the molecule steps will
lengthen to keep pace in this example we
increase the time step to a value over 3
million times longer from 300
femtoseconds to one microsecond or one
millionth of a second as a result the
steps increase in length to an average
value over a thousand times longer or
about the level that might be used to
simulate diffusion in a cell in this way
we illustrate another important
principle of diffusion
the average displacement changes as the
square root of a change in time in other
words if the time step is doubled the
average step length will increase only
by the square root of 2 and so on in our
movie the time step increases by more
than 1 million but the average step
length increases by a bit more than 1000
1000 is the square root of 1 million and
so in the movie you can actually see
this important relationship as we
revisit the beginning and end of the
path travelled by the glucose molecule
you
as we return to our lab bench we see
that Brownian dynamic simulations can be
carried all the way up to human scales
of space and time
for example millions of glucose
molecules can diffuse in a lab bigger
from minutes to hours as molecules
encounter surfaces like the beaker they
simply appear to bounce off using a
technique called specular reflection
just as light reflects from a mirror to
summarize molecular dynamics can be used
to study molecular structure and
function over time and space scales at
which inter-atomic forces are critical
for example in drug design and protein
structure prediction current
supercomputing research is pursuing new
ways to simulate more atoms and larger
molecules over longer periods of time on
the other hand Brownian dynamics can be
use to simulate diffusion at even longer
times relevant to cell biology coupling
Brownian dynamics to chemical reactions
is another area of active research and
these methods can be used to simulate
realistic models of cells and tissues
you